ou alors on ne sait pas si le débat mc
cain obama aura lieu ce soir mais la
campagne se poursuit et on sait aux
états unis tous les coups sont permis
les deux camps attaque régulièrement
l'adversaire par des vidéos
compromettantes sur internet la dernière
montre sarah palin connue pour ses
fortes convictions religieuses bénie par
un chasseur de sorcières
régis nussbaum la trier mes frères prier
pour sarah les images sont diffusées sur
le site de partage vidéo youtube
la scène remonte à trois ans en 2005
pendant une messe pentecôtistes dans son
sermon le prêcheur et fondateur de cette
église demande à ses fidèles de prier
pour celle qui n'a pas encore été élu
gouverneur de l'alaska
avant d'appeler à vaincre la sorcellerie
au nom de jésus au nom de jésus vous
devez rejeter toute forme de sorcellerie
au nom de gilles sors de ce corps tête
baissée
entouré par deux membres de la
congrégation de sarah palin écoutent
religieusement le serbe yeux ouvrez la
voix sahara même dans l'arène politique
apporter des fonds à sa campagne au nom
de jésus ses bénédictions teintées
d'exorcisme a déjà été regardée par des
millions d'américains
des images qui s'ajoute à une autre
vidéo où l'on pouvait voir et entendre
la colistière républicaine parler de la
mission divine des soldats américains en
irak
elle tombe en tout cas au plus mal pour
le camp républicain alors que john mc
cain est en chute libre dans les
sondages